this is a journey in America
a journey to four towns in the United
States in a time of war we begin where
the colonies began in what is now the
state of Virginia in 1607 settlers from
England came through this Bay on the
Atlantic coast
they gave the places names from home
James River and Elizabeth River
Portsmouth and Norfolk
today old Norfolk is a great naval base
the first settlers carried plain English
names Smith Kendal Newport Gosnold and
Goodrich
Wesley Goodrich is the name of this
machinist before the war the goodrich's
lived 50 miles to Norfolk in a six room
house he came here to work in the Navy
Yard so the family had to live in a
trailer until the government built
emergency war homes for the thousands of
workers who had flocked to the shipyards
these new houses looked something like
the first houses which the settlers put
up in the Old Dominion and like the
first settlements they were incomplete
the schools had not been constructed
the children thought this was fine
Vanessa Goodrich and her brothers ran
wild for a few days the people got
together to discuss the problem mrs.
Goodrich had an idea why not start up
the schools in a row of carriages the
people went to work
even the kids couldn't keep out of it
though they knew their help meant the
school would be open sooner
the headmaster had to find teachers he
found them right in the community many
of the wives of the war workers had
taught school back home
within a week the children were off the
streets they liked the new school it was
just like home same kind of house within
a few months the Alexander Park School
had the largest enrollment in the state
of Virginia never occurred to the people
of Alexander Park that they had done
anything notable schooling they said is
one thing that has to be made even in
wartime especially in wartime for
building the future citizens of a better
world is just as important as building
the weapons which will win it and secure
it
from the Virginia Shore he went by boat
it would pass the coasts of North and
South Carolina and Georgia you would
sail through the subtropical waters of
the Florida Strait to Alabama
this is the deep south Spanish explorers
came here first then the French in 1699
when pierre lemoyne established the
colony of fort Lloyd a llama beer now
the city of mobile
the old French colony lives on in the
quiet shady streets with their porches
of iron lace later mobile was cotton
queen of the world took her ease amidst
her miles of azaleas but now she is at
war
she builds cargo vessels and invasion
barges and to build them thousands of
workers poured in from every state in
the Union
this old city of 80,000 sold had to find
a place to live for over 200,000 people
bobby'll did her best she threw open her
mansions they became rooming houses with
beds and cots
a warehouse became a dormitory for girls
from the city of New York from the
mountains of Kentucky from the prairies
of Kansas who had come to take the
places of men as welders and ship
fitters
the newcomers spilled over into the
County trailers from Michigan and
Nebraska they camped in tents and in
hastily put together shacks even in old
trolley cars adapted into home
none of the modern conveniences
they had come here to build ships and
they lived as they had to live
government housing agencies attacked the
problem first thousands of emergency
trailers were rushed to mobile and set
up in colonies where electricity and
sanitation were provided
then immense temporary dormitories for
single men and war houses for families
it is not enough it can never be enough
but the workers are satisfied the
shipyards prove their satisfaction
from mobile everyday ships go down to
the sea to carry freedom back to the
lands from which its founders came
from Oh bill if you span the United
States due north it would come to the
city of Detroit in the state of Michigan
a frenchman antoine de la cardiac
founded Detroit in 1701 in peacetime the
city made automobiles for the world in
wartime it makes tanks and aircrafts for
the United Nations this is the bomber
Factory at Willow Run it works day and
night this is Kenneth Watson chief
inspector of final assembly 40,000 new
workers came to Willow Run in its first
year so some must live in trailers those
who work by night must sleep by day
Kenneth Watson could never get used to
his turn on night shift
watson said can't you keep those kids
quiet they have no place to play she
told him so he decided to build them a
playhouse he called together the men of
his Union in Detroit lumber is needed
for new war factories but there was
still some abandoned construction shacks
lying around they borrowed a truck from
the Union
mrs. Watson officiated at the laying of
the cornerstone each did his share it
wasn't exactly palatial they can do a
better job later on when the nursery
school and Recreation project for the
war workers gets underway in the
meantime the children have a place of
their own
and for evenings it has other uses these
Americans building the newest weapons of
war have followed a tune from the days
of the flintlock for getting things done
the words are join hands and go to it
heading west from detroit he would cross
the states of Michigan Wisconsin Iowa
Nebraska and Wyoming to the nation's
spine the rocky mark the train follows
the sunflower trail set in 1847 by the
Mormons
the City of Ogden in the state of Utah
is a railway Center where the
Transcontinental lines branch off for
Los Angeles San Francisco and Seattle on
the Pacific coast here is a vast supply
depot for the war in the Pacific stores
a material for the Army Navy and Air
Forces Arsenal's and warehouse
as simply weren't enough people in this
part of the state to man all these new
enterprises the army yards were clogged
with unloaded cars urgent cargoes were
delayed while ships waited in the
Pacific port
general Talbot sent Colonel Grice to
make one more attempt to find help there
was cash Valley
populated almost entirely but the
descendants of the Mormon pioneers the
people were busy Amos Griffin farmed for
only Danes with a clerk at ting wall
store HC Davis taught mathematics but
sunday was different Griffin played with
his children at home
they'll england's print shop was closed
while he pasted up photographs of his
sons at the front her oniy danes just
took it easy the sundays of the people
of cash valley were like sunday's all
over america until the army asked for
help
colonel grace met with the mayor the
town leaders and the deans of the
college they formed a plan
next Sunday at 4:00 in the morning the
school bus started to pick up the people
of cash Valley from all over the valley
the buses came carrying them to a
special train provided by the railroad
from Logan from Clarkston from Brigham
they came giving up their day of rest to
work for the army
the whole valley turned out
they unloaded 50 cars a hundred cars
marry Stanley typist
they stacked a quarter of a million
shovels bill England
Amos Griffin Maroney Danes
HC Davis the mathematics teacher they
loaded iron for the army
they stored rope for the Navy
they serve a steamrollers for new
airfields in the Solomons
they assembled urgent train loads for
the waiting ships every Sunday ten
thousand man-hours of labor the stuff of
war checked in headed out on schedule by
the people of cash Valley Utah
working for victory working for a better
world
like the people more than a thousand
miles away in Detroit Michigan in Mobile
Alabama and Norfolk Virginia in London
in Moscow in Chongqing